[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor john ross hello friends pastor
doug is out this evening this is pastor
sean ross but
how about an amazing fact now we've all
heard of homing pigeons but have you
ever heard about
homing penguins in 2012 retired 71 year
old johann d'souza
who lived near the south of rio de
janeiro
found a patagonian penguin on the shore
the poor creature was covered in oil and
starving
d'souza took the penguin home cleaned
him up gave him sardines and nursed him
back to health
along the way the two formed a special
bond
and de souza named his friendly bird
dindum
eventually the little penguin swam off
into the sunset
de souza's neighbors all said that that
would be the last he would ever see of
his feathered friend
but a few months later a happy dindum
waddled back to susa's home honking with
the light
and wagging its tail like a dog
biologists say that such penguins are
known to migrate
thousands of miles each year feeding and
breeding between colonies
but they have never heard of one bonding
with a human
d'souza says that he loves the penguin
as though it were his own child
and he believes that the penguin loves
him for the past several years the
penguin has come back to visit the man
who saved his life
each year he arrives in june and leaves
again
in february did you know friends that
in the bible we have a story of a man
whose life was saved
by birds stay tuned for more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
well friends welcome back to bible
answers live as mentioned a little while
ago pastor doug is out this evening but
this is a live
interactive international bible study
and we welcome your bible questions if
you have a bible related question the
number to call here to the studio is
800-463-7297
again that number is 800-463-7297
you can also join us if you'd like on
facebook we actually live streaming our
program this evening
at the amazing facts facebook page so
you're welcome to join us there
well in the amazing fact that we used to
open the program we spoke about
a person in the bible whose life was
saved by birds
now those of you who know your bible
you've probably guessed who this person
is
and if you guessed elijah you are
correct
first kings chapter 17 verse 6 says the
ravens brought him bread and meat in the
morning
and bread and meat in the evening and he
drank from the brook
this is during a time when there was
persecution coming against
elijah by jezebel and ahab the king
there was a famine in the land and god
provided for his prophet for elijah
by feeding him miraculously with food
that birds brought to him
now elijah is rather an interesting
bible character he was a
fearless spirit-filled preacher
he was also a prophet and the gift of
prophecy he was
translated to heaven without seeing
death
the bible records two individuals that
were taken to heaven without seeing
death
you have enoch before the flood you have
elijah
during the time of israel and we also
find elijah appearing
to jesus on the mount of transfiguration
in the new testament
along with moses who was resurrected and
taken to heaven after
he died and was buried on the mountain
now our free offer talks about
elijah elijah represents a special
movement in the last days of god's
people who are proclaiming
the elijah message calling people to
repentance proclaiming
a prophetic message found in the book of
revelation
and you might be wondering well what
does elijah have to do especially with
our day
and why did he appear to jesus well we
got a book we'd be happy to send you
it's called the two witnesses
uh written by pastor doug batchelor
talks about moses and elijah again the
book is called the two witnesses and if
you'd like to receive the book
just call our resource phone line and
that's 1-800-835-6747
again that's 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book called the
two witnesses moses and elijah
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls
and asks well we're going to go to the
phone lines again if you have a bible
related question
our phone line here to the studio is
800-463-7297
and uh first caller that we have is ron
listening in tennessee ron welcome to
the program
hello this is ron hi ron welcome i've
got a question
go ahead go ahead thank you um
my question is uh about revelation
chapter 17 verses
10 and 11. uh i don't quite follow what
it's
talking about sure let me read it and
then we can talk about it uh revelation
17 verse 10 says
there are also seven kings five have
fallen one is
and the other is not yet come and when
he comes he must continue a
short space and then verse 11 says the
beast that was and is not
uh is himself also the eighth and he's
of the seven
and he's going into perdition so of
course here in revelation chapter 17 we
have this picture of
a woman in chapter 17 writing a scarlet
colored beast
and she has on her floyd the name
written babylon the great the mother of
harlots
and then we get an explanation for the
different images that we see
and with reference to the beast's heads
there are seven heads
and the angel explains in verse 10 that
these seven heads
are seven mountains but they also
represent seven kings
in bible prophecy a king often
represents a kingdom as we can see in
the book of daniel
so who are these seven kings well these
are the seven
principal nations that have ward against
god's people
and it starts all the way back in the
time of israel
the first nation to really conquer and
occupy
the promised land was the nation of
assyria
they conquered the 10 tribes of the
north
the next is babylon which conquered
judah
and jerusalem took the jews captive for
70 years
the next kingdom that you have then is
meter persia
greece uh you have rome
and then in the new testament times
around you know during the middle ages
you have a church power the roman church
that was persecuting the protestants and
those who were holding to the truths of
the bible
so when it says there are seven kings
five or fallen there would be assyria
babylon meteor persia greece and rome
one is that would be the papal power
during the 1260 years of papal supremacy
during the dark ages
one is not yet come some of us some have
seen in that the
second beast of revelation 13 which is
the united states
it says when he comes he must continue a
short space
uh meaning in a persecuting position or
in a persecuting way he continues a
short space
and then of course the beast itself is
of the seven
and that again would be uh the papal
power
so that's one explanation of who the
seven kings are
so the people power will come back as
the eighth
after the seventh yes remember the papal
power received a deadly wound in 1798
when birthday napoleon general um
took the pope a prisoner uh but that
wound began to be healed when mussolini
gave back the vatican its independence
became a separate independent nation
and thus it is the power that was is not
and yet is
so that's talking about this deadly
wound the papacy recovers from that and
it continues to grow in
stature and influence especially public
politically
amongst the nations in the world so
you're saying that the seventh
is the united states the one that is yet
to come is the united states yes
which would be the seventh yeah right
okay and then the papacy will come back
again
as the eighth correct because it came
back already yes so once
yeah okay so it's going to grow in its
power
right so the united states in one sense
is going to set up and be a part of the
setup of
the papacy taking power against the
eight
correct and of course we can see that
happening in the news today where we see
great influence uh that the papacy has
uh
and they're extending that power to all
parts of the earth
not just in north america but south
american all over
okay that makes sense i got it now all
right well thanks for your call ron we
appreciate that
uh next caller that we have is george
listening in new jersey george welcome
to the program
hi how you doing tonight all right doing
good
okay i have a question uh on the
millennium i pretty much have been a
pre-millennialist for most of my study
all my life
but the the traditional
pre-millennialists where i believe that
the rain is on earth you know for a
thousand years but according to what
i've read
over the years with amazing facts and
you know your church
that uh you believe that the millennium
is in heaven for a thousand years and
that does seem pretty
credible looking at the new testament
but there's some of those difficult
passages and maybe you know what they
are in the old testament
that kind of talk about the lord
reigning over the earth but
it talks in the way that it sounds like
it's still when sin is going on there's
one in
isaiah i think 68 or 65
and one that's really puzzling to me is
maybe this is the one i want
i want you to concentrate on is
zechariah 14 you know it says the lord
will be king over all the earth yes
and it sounds like it's eternity but if
you go several verses down
it talks about people going up to keep
the feast of tabernacles
yes they don't do that there'll be no
rain upon them how is that how do you
explain that
in conjunction with the belief that the
rain is in heaven because
it seems like it's on the physical earth
where there is still sin
all right there's those difficult
passages that's a good question
um zechariah chapter 14 of course is
symbolic it's prophetic
and it's describing the reign of christ
on the earth now
i believe that when jesus comes the
second time the dead in christ are
raised the righteous are caught up to
meet the lord in the air
the wicked all destroyed and the devil
is bound to the earth with these angels
for a thousand years
the righteous go to heaven and they
there for a thousand years because jesus
said i'm going to go prepare places for
you in my father's house and then i'm
going to come and receive it unto myself
but at the end of the 1000 years
according to revelation chapter 21
john says i saw the new jerusalem
descending from god out of heaven
and when the new jerusalem descends all
the righteous will be in the city
and it's at that time that jesus sets
his foot as we have it described here in
zechariah chapter 14 on the mount of
olives and it opens up and forms a great
valley
and the new jerusalem comes to rest uh
so the righteous are inside the city
and the wicked who were dead prior to
this
are now resurrected and they stand on
the earth as the sand of the seashore
and the devil is there the angel there
and revelation then 20
describes what we call the great white
throne judgment
and at that point after the judgment
occurs
every knee bows every tongue confesses
that jesus christ is lord
and then there is a judgment that comes
upon the wicked because they mount their
attack upon the new jerusalem
and fire comes down and devours them and
then
according to revelation 21 god creates a
new heavens and a new earth
so what we see described here in
zechariah chapter 14
are events connected with what happens
at the end of that 1000 years when the
new jerusalem descends and comes down
from god out of heaven
because for example it says in that day
verse 4
in that day his feet shall stand upon
the mount of olives which faces
jerusalem on the east the mountain shall
be split in two
from the east to the west and then it
says
if you look back a little bit verse
three the lord will go forth and fight
against those nations
as he fights in the day of battle so the
wicked are mounting their attack upon
the new jerusalem
and judgment comes upon them and it's
described here in zachariah as
a great battle revelation talks about
the battle of armageddon where all the
nations are gathered before the lord
so um zechariah 14 is rarely referring
to events taking place at the end of the
thousand years
but that that part about the feast of
tabernacles that's the part that
confuses me
you know talks about some going up some
didn't go up and
they'll be judgment upon them like
there's still sin you see what i'm
saying
that's that's the possibility well there
will be there will be sin right up until
that final destruction of the wicked how
long
does that occur we don't know um right
the bible says the devil is
loose for a little season this is after
when the new jerusalem comes down and
the wicked are resurrected
the devil is loosed for a little season
he goes out to deceive the nations
whatever that is i mean there might be
enough time for groups to organize
themselves
and arrange rebellion against god they
might be those who refuse to come up
to jerusalem to acknowledge right the
lord so
you know some of those things we don't
have the specific details on it but i
think
zechariah 14 is referring to events that
take place at the end of that 1000 year
period
yeah some of those old testament texts
can be a little hard to understand you
know they can be and that's where you
got to kind of compare them with other
passages because
some of these old testament prophecies
had a historic application as well
two events that were to take place in
jerusalem to the jews
but it also had a broader prophetic
application
so you know jerusalem was conquered by
the enemies and god did fight for the
jews on several occasions
but this also refers to a much greater
event
that takes place at the at the end of
the thousand years
i see well anyway i only bring it up
because you know in
typical pre-millennial literature they
bring that up and
say that's a thousand year reign on the
earth you know but you're familiar with
that sure absolutely
as you as you're aware of yeah so um and
the amazing
facts teaching it's kind of unique you
can't find too many theologians that
teach that at least i haven't found it
in literature and i do a lot of
study on my own you know you know one of
the places you can go to find more about
this
is some of the early protestant
reformers
and theologians they they had a similar
view
on that when christ comes uh the
righteous would go to heaven for a
thousand years
now it might vary you know as they
looked at it and studied it
but some of the earlier reformers uh
some of the newer theology has become
very popular in these
in these last days um
is more a futuristic interpretation
um which includes that so i like to go
back to even the
earlier reformers and and some of those
theologians they have some real solid
material i'll try to google that and
look up some of those yeah
sounds good well thanks for your call
george all right
all right thanks thanks george and again
we want to remind those who are
listening if you have not yet
seen or read the amazing facts study
guide called a thousand years of peace
it talks about this one thousand year
period that george and i were just
talking about
uh talks about zechariah 14 as well as
revelation chapter 20 and 21
and you'll be blessed if you'd like to
receive that study guide the number to
call is 800-835-6747 that is the
resource phone line
and just ask for the thousand years of
peace and we'll put that in the mail and
send it to you
we've got chris listening in florida
chris welcome to the program
oh thank you hello yes
you're on the air yes i i have a
question about uh
you know jesus says um in
the gospel of luke of or matthew
he says that every sin can be forgiven
but the same
except for the sin against the holy
spirit
blasphemy of the holy spirit but how
does it relate to
um the story which is in the
levitic leviticus
the case of blasphemy the law you know
by that man that
his mother was israelite and the father
egyptian and he black family there
name of the lord and
[Music]
he that the lord said to moses that he
should be stoned
correct so kaiser how should we
understand that
um blasphemy of the holy spirit in new
testament okay good question
yeah equals the blasphemy of god
yeah well let me let me see if i can say
a few things about that the verse you're
referring to
is in matthew 12 31 i'm going to read it
for those who
might be traveling and might not have
their bibles handy it says therefore i
say unto you the words of jesus
every sin and blasphemy will be forgiven
men
but the blasphemy against the spirit
will not be forgiven men
now the example that you mentioned there
chris was a person who blasphemed
against god
but they were unrepentant and therefore
they were not forgiven
we have other examples in the bible of
people who sinned
and were unrepentant and judgment came
achen stole that which was not his from
jericho and judgment came upon him and
there were many other examples of that
that we have in the bible but we also
have examples in the bible of people who
were repentant
and who were forgiven for example you've
got moses who
killed an egyptian and then had to flee
for his life but
he was repentant god forgave him god
used moses in a mighty way
david guilty of committing adultery as
as well as indirect murder of
of uriah and yet he was forgiven so
uh every sin as jesus says can be
forgiven but one that can't be forgiven
is blasting against the holy spirit what
does that mean well the bible tells us
that it's the goodness of god that leads
us to repentance
and blessing against the holy spirit is
when someone puts themselves in the
place of the holy spirit
meaning they reject the holy spirit they
harden their hearts to the promptings of
the spirit of god
and if it's the goodness of god that
leads us to repentance and it's the holy
spirit
that does that if we grieve away the
holy spirit if we harden our hearts
against the holy spirit
how are we to come to the point of
repentance
how are we going to ask for forgiveness
and if we don't repent we don't ask for
forgiveness
we can't be forgiven so that's why the
sin that can't be forgiven is the
blasphemy against the holy spirit it's
not a single sin
that someone might commit sometimes
people ask well maybe i committed
the sin against the holy spirit no if
you're wondering about that
you probably haven't it means the holy
spirit is speaking to your heart
but then again we don't want to we don't
want to neglect the promptings of the
holy spirit
we want to allow the spirit to guide us
through the word of god
uh does that help chris yes
but when you when you talk about
repentance
i heard on the radio from many pastors
say that
repentance is a gift from god but it's
not
always available well repentance is
available to anyone who seeks it
those who don't seek it those who harden
their hearts against the holy spirit
they are not given repentance it's not
that god doesn't want to
lead them to repentance and god is not
willing that any should perish but that
all should come to repentance but
they've hardened their heart against the
promptings of the spirit and there's
nothing more god can do for them
they've in essence chosen their path and
their minds have been
set in going their own way you know we
do have a book
chris that kind of talks a little bit
about this and it's called the
unpardonable
sin or the sin that can't be forgiven
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who wants to learn more
about the subject of the unpardonable
sin
the number to call is 800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for that book
talking about
the unpardonable sin or the sin against
the holy spirit
and there's a lot of bible verses there
it's a very good and important subject
so i want to encourage you to call and
ask for that thank you for calling chris
we have
audrey listening from oregon audrey
welcome to the program
thank you my call tonight is regarding
judges 11.
i've i've been studying about jephthah's
daughter
and he when he vowed to god that he
would
sacrifice as a birth offering excuse me
um
to whatever walked out of his door first
and it happened to be his only daughter
and i've heard
i always thought that it was sort of
like hannah offering
her son samuel to the temple to be
raised you know dedicated to god
but recently i heard that um he did
indeed
um offer his daughter as a burnt
offering
if that is why would why would god
require that
right no he didn't he didn't offer as a
burnt offering
um he had an animal come out a clean
animal
had a sheep or a goat or even a cow if
he had one
if that would have been the first thing
that would have approached him as he
came home
he would have offered that as a burnt
sacrifice as an offering but if
his donkey happened to be the first
thing to come he wouldn't have offered
his donkey as a sacrifice because that
was forbidden
as well as human sacrifices was
forbidden
so in the case of his daughter what did
he do well he dedicated her
to the service and to the work in the
sanctuary
and she never got married and that's why
you read on it talks about her friends
they bewail her virginity because she
never had any children
she stayed loyal to the lord she stayed
faithful
you know in the new testament we have a
story of um
a prophetess by the name of anna and you
remember how she was
also coming to the temple regularly she
provides service she helped in different
ways in the temple
and she was also you know she was a
widow she wasn't married
um so jephthah's daughter was
consecrated to the service of the lord
in the work of the sanctuary she was not
offered up as a sacrifice
okay well that makes me feel a lot
better because i've heard
pastors recently say that she was indeed
offered as a burnt sacrifice
and a burnt offering and then i went on
the internet and it said most of the
people
do believe that and there's a portion
that believe
what you just said yeah well you know i
think there's enough evidence just in
the verse itself
in the passage that would refer to the
fact that
she did live the rest of her life in
service
for the lord in the temple she never did
get married
she never had children of course the
bible tells us
many places that any type of sacrifice
that is unclean or any human sacrifice
is an abomination to the lord
so he couldn't accept that and then i
heard just recently
otherwise so that's why that's why i
called good
well thank you so much all right thanks
for calling audrey appreciate it
all right next caller that we have is
let's see we've got emmanuel
calling from ghana africa emmanuel
welcome to the program
hello pastor rose good morning good good
morning to you there yeah
how about you please doing good and your
question
okay my question is uh in matthew
chapter 4 verse 1 to 10
uh it reads that jesus christ was
tempted by the devil
so i i just want to know that the devil
appears as a human being or
he was in the spirit tempting the lord
okay good question
well you know the bible says the devil
can transform himself into an angel of
light
and um one would assume that at least
the first time
the first temptation he probably came to
christ
and appeared to be an angel sent from
god
to help deliver jesus because of course
he hadn't eaten for a long period of
time
jesus was very weak he was tired and he
probably showed up as if he was
an answered prayer of christ saying you
know if you are the son of god
turn these stones to bread but it didn't
take jesus very long to realize
this was not an angel sent from god this
was indeed the devil
and then if you read on little in the
story it seems as though at some point
the devil gives up
on this masquerade of of being a good
angel because
the third temptation he says if you bow
down and worship me
i will give you all the kingdoms of this
earth so it seems by that time the devil
realized that
christ knew who he really was and so he
didn't hide his identity anymore and he
said
if you bow down worship me i'm going to
give you the kingdoms and jesus said get
thee behind me satan so
maybe the first temptation he first
appeared as an angel of light
but then as time went on he eventually
revealed who he
really is emmanuel thank you for your
call all the way from africa that's good
good question uh we don't have time to
take another uh caller because we're
coming up on our break the program is by
no means
over we're just getting started so if
you have a bible related question it's
not too late to call
the number here to the studio is
800-463-7297
and that'll bring you here to the studio
again that's 800-463-7297
and i'll be giving another number that
you might want to write down this is our
resource
phone line and this is 800-835-6747
and we're going to be offering different
resources that we think will be a great
benefit to you
in your bible study so we have some
important announcements
and then we'll be back to take more
bible questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live hello friends welcome
back to bible answers live
my name is john ross pastor doug is out
this evening
but our phone lines are open this is a
live program and if you have a bible
related question we would love to hear
from you this evening
the number to call is 800-463-7297
and that'll get you here to the studio
you can also join us at the amazing
facts facebook page
are we going to go straight back to the
phone lines we've got james listening in
brooklyn new york
uh james welcome to the program thank
you pastor
my question is who was on earth first
satan or adam
all right who was on earth first satan
adam well
satan was probably watching when god
created adam and eve
and he was looking for the perfect
opportunity and coming up with the best
way in which he could try
and tempt and deceive them and of course
we know the story how that he
transformed himself into a
snake in the tree that god had said
don't eat of it
so the war in heaven occurred before the
creation of the earth
uh you can read in revelation chapter 12
and verse 7
it says there was war in heaven michael
and his angels fought with the dragon
and the dragon and his angels fought
but they did not prevail nor was a place
found for them in heaven any longer
so the dragon was cast out that old
serpent of all called the devil and
satan who deceives the whole world
he was cast to the earth and his angels
were cast out with him
so the devil was cast out of heaven he
sort of floated around space looking for
a place that he could maybe claim as his
somewhere in within that time period god
creates the earth
and he sees adam and eve and he says ah
let me see if i can get them on my side
and he was successful in his deception
and he deceived adam and eve and then
this world became
his dominion at least he claimed it to
be his dominion
but christ who is the second adam has
gained it back and now jesus is our
representative
thank you very much all right thanks you
called james
uh we've got richard listening from uh
guyana richard welcome to the program
yeah thank you yes and your question
tonight
yes i would like you to explain to me
the difference between
papal rome and pagan rome okay very good
um when we talk about papal rome or
pagan rome
papal rome is uh the power that was
ruling at the time of christ
it's uh pagan rome they had a number of
deities that they worshipped
of course one of the gods they
worshipped was the caesar
uh it was a persecuting power it is very
um
it was very hard on the jewish people
it was hard on the christians there was
persecution from rome
against the early christian church but
at the conversion of constantine
to christianity christianity was then
legalized within the roman empire
and as the roman empire began to fall
apart
because of these invading germanic
tribes that had come from
north east and began to conquer and
occupy the territory that
rome held the
pagan rome began to wane while
papal rome that is the church based in
rome
the roman catholic church the papal
power began to grow
and eventually the papal power became
larger and more powerful and ruled a lot
longer
than pagan rome at the beginning of that
time period was
uh the establishment of the papal power
in 357
and gold went all the way through till
when the papers received its deadly
wound so that's the difference between
the papal rome
and the pagan rome does that help
richard
yes it does thank you all right thank
you for your call all the way from
uh guyana we've got peter listening in
new jersey peter welcome to the program
hello pastor how are you tonight doing
well
i'm just going to switch phones so i
could hear you a little bit better okay
okay pastor now when we read the bible
it's pretty clear we're never to take
uh vengeance on anyone or pour wrath out
on anyone and
you know the verse is like in proverbs
where it says don't pour wrath out on
anyone lest the lord see it
and he turns his wrath away from them
and then
vengeance is mine i will repay says the
lord so when some so when someone
causes us harm and we don't take
vengeance now the lord does
take vengeance on that person could we
be happy about it or are we to be
sad about it well you know the bible
tells us to pray for enemies
and that would include them in any
condition so
sometimes people just reap the
consequences of
bad decisions it might not be a direct
judgment from god sometimes it is
but sometimes it could also be them
reaping what they have sowed but
from our perspective we want to pray for
those who persecute though
persecute us we want to pray for our
enemies because we don't know
where they are spiritually maybe through
this experience
their hearts might be open to bible
truth they might be willing to
come to christ and receive forgiveness
and we want to be there
as an encouragement so i don't think we
should
you know rejoice and say ah you see i
told you you shouldn't have messed with
me
god's god's judging you because of that
i think we should have an attitude of
a willingness to help if we can and uh
placing them in god's hands maybe this
is an opportunity for us to witness
maybe this attorney
experience in their life very good
pastor one more question do you have a
favorite uh
commentary from the bible about the
bible from maybe like around the
reformed
time of period yes there are several uh
good commentaries that i sometimes will
refer to
um and there is a program it's free it's
called
e-sword and you can download that on
your computer
and you can actually download different
comment
commentaries from the reformers gill is
one
henry is another these are classics and
you can actually download them for free
because they're all public domain
and you can you can read those so that's
a good resource
thank you so much sir good night now all
right thank you peter uh we got jerry
listening from oregon jerry
welcome to the program yes
uh uh pastor ross i i'm blown away i
i was planning to ask the question your
second caller asked about
but there's a excuse me an important
point that
you did not expound upon now
zechariah 14 verse 16 let me read it to
you
then the survivors from all the nations
that have attacked jerusalem will go up
year after year to worship the king
so these are the survivors after the
attack and then they're still there
and they're still subject to sanctions
in the form of drought and plagues
now again that's and the question is
well how could that be
after the earth is recreated and all
things are new is that what you want
is that where you're going with that
well
basically i mean i i know from the
previous uh sermons that your church's
position
is that when jerusalem is attacked the
evil are destroyed
and there's basically paradise on earth
from that point on
but this scripture doesn't corroborate
that
well what i see happening here in
zechariah chapter four
is uh at the end of the 1000 years when
the new jerusalem comes down
from god out of heaven revelation
chapter 21 the wicked all resurrected
and there is a period of time how long
that is the bible doesn't say
but during that time period the wicked
gather themselves together
in opposition to god and there is a
point where
they do mount their attack upon the new
jerusalem and they are destroyed
now as i said zechariah chapter 14 has
applications that apply to the nation of
israel
and their experience as well as
application to
what happens in the kingdom that christ
establishes at the end of the thousand
years
similar to what you have in matthew 24
you have signs of the destruction of
jerusalem that occurred in 70 a.d
mixed in with signs of the second coming
of christ
so i i don't think we can take
everything in zechariah chapter 14 and
say this all applies
to a historical occurrence that happened
to israel
sometime in the old testament period nor
can we say
everything in zechariah chapter 14 is
going to occur
exactly as described at the end of the
1000 years when
jerusalem comes down there are some
applications
that apply to events that occurred in
jerusalem and to the enemies
but there are also a number of things in
zechariah 14 that will only apply
at the end of the 1000 year period
well are you saying then the scripture i
just read
does not apply to the period of time
after the millennium
when new jerusalem comes down and
there's an atta and there's a
resurrection of the unjust
and then there's an attack on the new
jerusalem because
again this is what it says then the
survivors
from all the nations that have attacked
jerusalem
will go up year after year to worship
the king
and then it talks about sanctions if
they don't
and as i said there could be this time
period
prior to their final destruction that
you know we think of this final
destruction is maybe
happening instantaneously but we don't
know how much time
elapses from the resurrection of the
wicked at the end of the thousand years
to
the final destruction how does this
verse apply
you know i don't know we'll have to see
this is talking about things that are
yet to come in the future
how it all fits together um you know
it's difficult to say
we will probably understand a lot better
when that time comes
but it does say survivors from the
nations that attack jerusalem
but but before we i'd also like to
mention
something similar in revelation 20. now
i realize this is talking about an
earlier time
uh revelation 20 uh
verse 3. now this is referring to satan
he threw him into the abyss and locked
and sealed it over him
to keep him from deceiving the nations
anymore
now now obviously this is the beginning
of the millennium
right but but it's it but you people are
contending that the word
the world is is desolate at that point
so it'd be a very odd way of stating
that the world's desolate if there's
nations there
uh and uh and and
satan has gone so that he will not
deceive them well the reason
the devil is unable to deceive the
nations is because the nations
are not there this bottomless pit
well the bottomless pit is the earth
left in this chaotic
condition after the second coming of
christ
we are where the wicked are destroyed or
the brightness of christ coming
the devil is bound to the abusos in the
greek there which means a dark
desolate empty chaotic place
and he's there for a thousand years
during the 1000 years when the righteous
oil in heaven
you know jerry we have a study guide
i've got to keep moving along to our
next caller but we have a study guide
called a thousand years of peace
and it is uh very detailed and goes into
these different verses
and i think you'll enjoy reading it if
you haven't read it yet a call and
answer it
the number is 800-835-6747
and take a look at that study called a
thousand years of peace and then
maybe we can talk about those verses
after you have a chance to look at that
thanks for call we've got robert
listening in washington robert welcome
to the program
hello pastor ross hi
um i guess you can hear me i can
i my question was regarding uh first
peter 4
6 uh i was just wanting to know if you
could explain that especially the the
last part about
living according to god in the spirit
all right let me read the verse for
those who might not have the bible in
front of them it says
first peter 4 6 for this reason the
gospel is preached also to those who are
dead
that they might be judged according to
men in the flesh
but live according to god in the spirit
so your question on there is who are the
dead people and who are the living
people in the verse
correct yeah and and what it means by
living according to god in the spirit as
well
okay let's break the verse up because i
think it'll make it a little
clearer it says for this reason the
gospel was preached also to those who
are dead
that they might be judged according to
men in the flesh
so the gospel was preached to those who
even peter's particularly talking about
those
in old testament times the gospel is
preached to them in
types and shadows through christ
and we can look at that even now and we
could see yes the gospel was preached to
them through the sacrificial system
through the sanctuary uh we live
according to god
in the spirit so uh our lives now
need to be spirit-led and
spirit-governed
they had the gospel preached as we have
the gospel preached
we were preached the gospel through
christ through the apostles
they would preach the gospel through the
types and the ceremonies
that god had given the jewish people and
you know
that's kind of the general theme that
peter is getting at is that
the jews they are not without excuse
they had the gospel preached to them
even as new testament believers had the
gospel preached to them
i think i read one time where peter
where
it was saying that um first peter
when they first wrote the bible there
wasn't any commas or a punctuation kind
of thing
and it could be referring to the first
peter
first period three where it talks about
the anti-deluvians
yes and he does talk about the
antediluvian world that had the gospel
preached to them as well
so you know it's talking about those in
the old testament times
who did have the gospel and they they
are without excuse
but we have even less of an excuse
because we have a clearer
preaching of the gospel that's come
through christ and through the word
okay well thank you pastor all right
thanks for call robert appreciate it
next caller that we have is jonathan and
uh jonathan is listening
in canada jonathan welcome to the
program
hello hi jonathan you on the air
hello pastor john hi how old are you
jonathan
how old are you
i'm good are you good all right good how
many years old are you
what's your age i'm sick oh you're six
okay
very good what's your question jonathan
my question is why did david have to
fight goliath
okay well god had told
seoul who was the king at the time that
judgment was to come against the
philistines or the philistines because
they were warring against god's people
against israel
and goliath was this giant
and uh there were none of the soldiers
of seoul
none of the jewish soldiers who were
willing to fight him because they were
afraid
but daniel said if god is for us
we don't have to be afraid god will give
us the victory
and so david fought goliath and sure
enough he got the victory
and of course we know we have that
wonderful story in the bible about david
and goliath so david fought goliath
because
he was doing what god had asked the
israelites to do
in conquering the philistines
all right jonathan
thank you all right you're welcome thank
you for your call
all right we have uh ralph listening in
michigan ralph welcome to the program
yes yes
yes how's it going good yes um yes i was
gonna uh
gosh i need some clarification since
jesus ate
will we have to have a um bowel movement
um even though we will have a glorified
body okay
well we do know that when jesus rose
from the dead he did eat but
you know we yeah we also know that
christ is a bit of a different dimension
than we are because
he appears and then he disappears uh
we also know that jesus was caught up
and he went up to heaven
and so he had the glorified body
the bible doesn't say i don't think it's
necessary
with the glorified body because you know
we'll be able to travel through space
uh we'll be able to live out there where
uh
normally with our bodies now we can't so
we don't know exactly what the the
glorified bodies are going to be like
but
one thing we do know is that we are
going to be able to eat
and that we have that example given to
us of jesus
and we also um go to go go through walls
we will actually go by the um
speed of thought really too well you
know probably we'll have to travel a
little faster than light because
okay it's going to take a long time so
yes there's going to be some kind of
travel we know the angels can
travel very quickly so maybe we get to
travel the same way they do
but uh that's something we'll have to
find out when jesus comes
okay all right thanks rob thank you so
much appreciate your call
all right next quarter that we have is
andrew listening in new mexico andrew
welcome to the program
yes i just needed to ask you a question
sure we're going to
share in the bible about the ufos
well you know the bible doesn't say
anything about ufos we do know that
there
are good angels and we know they are bad
angels
and i think it is possible for the devil
to maybe try and um
impersonate something or someone or or
make somebody see something or maybe try
to scare someone
but uh the other worlds aren't coming
and visiting our world
in flying sources uh the bible doesn't
say anything about that
i see and watch you don't have any
scriptures i can go
uh go by well if you're asking
specifically about
ufos um the bible doesn't say anything
about ufos but it does talk about
other worlds and this is in hebrews
chapter 1 where it says
through christ god created the worlds
and it uses the plural form
and then in the book of job job chapter
1 it talks about
a meeting that occurred with the sons of
god
these weren't people from earth because
the devil came
representing the earth so there are
other created worlds out there with
intelligent beings we don't believe that
they send seems like our world is the
only one that sinned
um they aware of what's happening
and they can communicate with angels
they can communicate with god
so we will get to visit these worlds
when jesus comes but as far as ufos
coming and snatching people and taking
them off to
planets uh there's nothing in the bible
that talks about that
and when does the three and a half years
start we're now at the time of the end
so when does the three half years start
what is it what scripture in the bible
where it says well there's no scripture
that says specifically that they are
three and a half years just before jesus
comes
but the bible does tell us that there
are certain signs that will take place
before christ comes there's an increase
of natural disasters there's floods
there's tornadoes
there is um unrest between nations
wars rumors of wars there are
pestilences diseases
and then the final thing just before
jesus comes you have the outpouring of
the seven last plagues
but it doesn't say it's going to be
three and a half years it might be
we don't know but the bible does not
specifically say
that it's three and a half years
and those people and other uh galaxies
will get to see him and
where did they come from they were
created by god
and um you know we will get to see them
god created the angels he created other
beings in on other worlds and
yeah after jesus comes i i think we will
have an opportunity to to visit
um and that'll be kind of neat to travel
through the universe
and meet these other created beings on
other worlds well andrew thank you again
for your call i'm going to try and take
one more maybe two more before we uh run
out of time we've got
daniel listening in arizona daniel
welcome to the program
hello pastor how you doing doing well
thanks
okay well um yeah my question was uh the
the gentleman that just uh
about the other world you know i've been
reading a lot on the uh
on other books you know uh out of
respect to the the young lady
i said i'm not gonna go specifically who
who i'm reading from but i think we all
know who
we're talking about here um now she
she does say that that she does go to
other worlds and
as you said in hebrews um
that there is other worlds uh
when god created us in his likeness did
he create
everybody else in his likeness or will
he is he talking specifically
about us on earth okay um it seems as
though for for
us for the human race we were a little
different than
uh the other creation and uh the reason
we say that is because
it says god said let us make man in our
image according to our likeness
and what's unique about the human race
versus angels uh is that we can
procreate
in our image uh the the angels can't do
that
the devil can't do that and i think
that's one of the reasons he hates us so
much
but we god has given us the ability to
create
uh in our own image a life or a likeness
unto ourselves in our children
so and we get to share a very special
experience with our children
uh a love and um a belonging
that reflects on the way god feels about
us
so um can the other worlds procreate
i i don't think so i mean the bible
doesn't say for sure
but i think we're unique in that sense
in when god said let us make man in our
image
and he made them male and female we know
angels are not made
male and female they're just uh
beings or they being special or
something right powerful beings
intelligent beings very powerful beings
absolutely absolutely so
well thank you very much and uh god
bless you all right thanks for your call
daniel
um we've got uh johnny maybe we have
time for one more johnny listening from
alabama johnny welcome to the program
hey thank you how you doing i'm doing
well
okay here's the question okay in the
book of acts
chapter 9 when
paul was on the road i think to damascus
or uh-huh
yes and he said in verse seven nine and
seven
and the men which journeyed with him
stood
speechless hearing a voice
but seeing no man when you go to
acts 22 and verse 9 when paul was
testifying about this thing that
happened
in acts chapter 9 he said
he said this and they that were with me
saw indeed the light
and were afraid but they
heard not the voice of him that spake to
me
and i've that have always pulled with me
okay
chapter nine it says he did right so
um the way i've seen it and i think it
makes sense
is what happened to those who are with
paul
they saw the light they heard a voice
but they could not understand
what was being said they didn't hear
when god said soul saul why are you
persecuting me
they didn't understand that they didn't
know that maybe
they heard the noise but they couldn't
understand what it was
only saul who is converting becomes paul
actually understood the message that god
was giving him
and of course as you know that led to
his conversion
and he repeats that several times so
they heard something but they couldn't
identify the voice they couldn't hear
exactly what god said
to paul only paul was able to hear that
thank you for your call johnny i'm
looking at the clock we don't have time
to take another call but we want to
thank all of those who called in this
evening
if he didn't get to your question call
us again next week we're going to have
another live program and we'll be happy
to take your bible questions
until then god bless
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted
by pastor doug batchelor explores the
most striking bible prophecies
that have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at
afbookstore.com or by calling
1-800-538-7275
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6700
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org